sup
what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome to a little video
so the year 2021 has just begun
it's new year usually at the beginning
of each year i like to give you guys a
bit of an update
and more or less a little plan for the
year last year i think i did that
i don't remember to be honest as soon as
the video is done it's just
just out of my mind this year this year
going to be quite a special year i think
because for me
it's the year of creation
the year of creating actual content
around two years ago
i started building a game engine called
hazel and
i mean it's been a wild journey so far
there's two parts to hazel there's the
game engine series which is just a
essentially an episodic kind of tutorial
series in which i teach how to actually
make a game engine
but then there's also this thing called
hazel dev which to me is just
hazel and that is essentially my version
of
this game engine so on one hand i'm
teaching how to make a game engine
that's based on
my game engine which is called hazel a
lot of people have no idea what hazel
hazel dev is all that stuff you get
questions all the time probably my fault
for making it so difficult to understand
but hopefully that clears it up a little
bit just in case you're confused
anyway so whilst the kind of game engine
series version of hazel is still
quite primitive i mean we can kind of
draw 2d quads in like a 3d space and
like move the camera around and we have
like an anti-component system
it's still very very bare bones of
course because it takes time to build up
a game engine if you're
showing and explaining everything in an
episode episode kind of basis but on the
other hand hazeldev which actually
started from hazel so they started
around the same time and i'm pretty sure
i kind of took a copy of hazel's code
base the game engine series version of
hazel's code base
and then branch that off into what is
hazeldev now that started around two
years ago but that's not attached to
like a video tutorial series so it's
essentially just me developing
my game engine as fast as i can whenever
i have time now from that i've also kind
of turned that development into like the
hazel devlogs and there's
there's people from the community like
peter an electron diffuser helping out
and as a result
it's matured quite quickly and it's
getting to the point where
we can actually start using it to make
something over the past few months
you've probably seen
in various dialogues such as like
shadows and like there's a 3d physics
one i'll have it linked up there
so you can check it out but you've
probably seen that the engine's kind of
coming together really quickly we're
just slapping in features left right
we're getting stuff in super quick and i
get asked very
often what my motivation for that is why
am i building a game engine if
unity exists unreal exists godot exists
there's all these kind of
existing engines why am i building yet
another engine
now first of all like i don't want to
get too much into that question i made a
video on that topic anyway
just because something exists doesn't
mean you shouldn't make it yourself i
mean maybe if you're
you know super oriented on finding like
some kind of niche and monetizing that
and being really successful
then maybe that's not the best thing to
do especially with the complexity of a
game engine
but ultimately you know just don't let
someone stop you from doing something
just because it's already been done
before
there are so many situations in which
something unique comes out of something
existing because a person has a
completely different viewpoint
upon that particular problem that
they're trying to solve but anyway the
whole point of hazel for me
is to use it as a platform for me to
create art
in the form of games for me a video game
is
an interactive story that's how i see
games
i'm not much of a gamer i guess myself i
don't spend too much time playing games
but the games that i do like and the
games that i appreciate
are ones that have a rich story to them
before i became a
game developer or started working in the
games industry i was really into
film i loved making films i wanted to
become like a filmmaker a film director
producer even a visual effects artist at
one
point i was really into storytelling
and for me this whole industry and what
i'm building with hazel
is a platform upon which i can tell my
stories
the only difference is the the format
really instead of them being
a film that you sit down and watch
they're going to be an interactive
game now making games is very difficult
for anyone who has made a game or worked
in the industry you know
that you don't need me to tell you that
it's it's
very difficult to make a game but for me
a game doesn't necessarily have to
have aaa graphics or be realistic
looking or have like this
huge like infinite supply of things to
do which
modern games tend to kind of aim for for
me as an artist a game is a way to
convey a particular feeling a particular
mood tell a particular story
that can be accomplished in whatever
abstract way
you want because that's the beauty of
art i know that a lot of you out there
want to make games
and i haven't really spoken on that
topic very much
because i've been more focused on the
technology behind
games a lot of independent games fail
because
their scopes are simply too high people
want to make like an mmo rpg
fps whatever and that's just completely
unfeasible to do
in a small team or as a solo developer
my plan isn't exactly
that of course i would say i am aiming
for quite an
ambitious game here because i have a
particular
i have a particular feeling that i want
to convey and
in order to do that i think that i need
some level of detail and complexity
it's super exciting that the technology
that i've been building is getting up to
the point where
it can actually be used for its intended
purpose which is ultimately to create
content and that's ultimately what i
want to say with this video
is just the fact that this year 2021
is the year where we transform hazel
from
just being like a piece of technology
that we use to create little sandbox
environments to test out various
rendering techniques and like
integrations we take it from that into
something that's able to
actually produce art and that's
extremely exciting and i can't wait to
just spend this year
making things even though i'm a
programmer software engineer i don't
just see
myself as that i see myself as more of
an artist ultimately
and so it's really exciting for me to
finally be able to actually create
things because i've been
i've just been waiting for that moment
honestly i've just been developing my
technology kind of quietly
waiting to get to the point where i can
actually start producing
things with it so that is the plan for
this year now obviously there's still a
lot of work to be done in hazel
i'm not saying hazel's finished i'm just
saying that it's
getting to the point where the content
is going to start driving the
development instead of just arbitrarily
developing a game engine that
needs to do xyz because that's what a
game engine needs to do
that's what tools we need to create so
that we can actually make something
we're kind of getting past that stage
and more into i need this feature for
this scene
we need to implement that now and that
is a very exciting bridge to cross when
making a game engine
now this game that i'm making i want to
take you guys along with me
for this journey but i also don't want
to reveal too much
just because we don't really know what's
we don't really know what direction it's
taking exactly with just concepts kind
of concept art and concept ideas at this
point but what i do want to do
is while we are kind of still in this
pre-production stage uh
there are a lot of experiments happening
with hazel like for example we need to
make sure that hazel is set up to handle
the art style
and the art direction that we've chosen
to go with so we need to make sure that
we can render grass and have it look
like we want for example so all of those
kind of things i really want to share
with you and i'm going to
try my best to kind of make devlogs i've
also
i've also got this huge backlog of like
hazel dev topics to cover like the
shadow stuff and
the physx there's more physics stuff to
cover and see shops
i think the best way to do this is going
to be
just by taking input from you guys if
there's something particular that you
want to see please leave a comment below
because that would be that would be nice
maybe that will help me kind of
prioritize the videos that i make if you
guys have any questions about anything
i've talked about if there's anything
you want to see me make a video on
please let me know
the general plan for videos this year is
going to be
you know everything that used to exist
is going to stay i mean ultimately i'm
gonna be still focused on the game
engine series i'm gonna aim for one
episode every week for that and that
will still be live streamed on twitch tv
slash the channel
um that's also where i happen to work on
hazel dev during those live streams as
well so definitely give that a follow if
you are interested
the hazel devlogs are of course going to
continue and they might even get more
frequent i'm hoping and then on the
other side of things with like just
random i guess vlogs or like c plus
videos
and like the code review series that
stuff is just gonna happen
when when i have a spare moment
ultimately the thing that i'm
prioritizing this year is making actual
content
making making actual content with hazel
and that's what every that's what this
year is going to be focused on
a lot of people have also been asking me
if i'm going to attempt to make a game
in an hour with hazel
like i did a little over a year ago and
the answer is yes
um there are a few like workflow
improvements i have to make
to hazeldev first but i think i'm gonna
take hazel dev
and attempt to make that flappy bird
style game
again or something similar i don't know
we'll see
but basically like you know using hazel
using hazel to make stuff
is the priority this year and whilst my
wife and i are
kind of embarking on this huge journey
to actually build a game
there will be a lot of mini games i
think along the way that
you know either going to show off a
particular concept or just
as examples that we developed for hazel
as well anyway i think i'm going to end
the video
here if you guys liked this video please
don't forget to hit the like button let
me know what your thoughts are
in the comment section below if you want
to support hazel and me
and like everything that i'm doing here
then please go to patreon.com
the channel and become a patron that is
by far the best way to support
this supporting me on patreon depending
on the tier will give you access to
hazel dev so everything that i show in
the hazel devlogs you can actually
download all that source code check it
out for yourself
run it try and make something in
hazeldev yourself if you want to
as well as like an entire backlog of
like live streams and various other kind
of exclusive content but thank you
to everyone who has been with me on this
journey so far
i think that the stuff that we're doing
is super cool i'm
really excited for the future and i mean
my main goal
i think with hazel is to ship a game and
i think we're finally
finally getting to the beginning of that
journey so thank you all for your
support
hope you enjoyed the rest of this year
as much as i hopefully will and for
those of you sitting at home
thinking oh cool this channel guys got
such an exciting year planned
there's no reason why you can't do the
same so if anything
make this the year of making things make
it happen
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you